jean françois copé le président de l'ump
est l'invité de preuves par 3 bonsoir
choisi d'honorer ce rendez-vous de
public sénat avec l' agence
france-presse et dailymotion avec nous
tout à l'heure des bras claude de la fp
et perrine tarneaud de public sénat pour
aborder bien sûr la situation politique
celle du gouvernement celle de
l'opposition celle du gouvernement avec
le report de la loi famille vous aviez
demandé
la démission de michel sapin après la
progression du chômage est ce que vous
demandez aujourd'hui la démission de la
ministre de la famille dominique
bertinotti même si elle peut se sentir
renforcés lieu par la colère et les
propositions à venir des députés
socialistes ces deux sujets différents
pour ce qui concerne michel sapin vous
savez il ya quand même une réalité le
président de la république s'est engagé
personnellement a mis sa crédibilité
dans la balance auprès des français sur
l'idée de dire aux baissera le chômage
c'est promis on a la solution miracle
les contrats aidés c'est à dire des
contrats de public avec de l'argent
public le pire étant d'ailleurs dans le
même temps ils ont baissé les contrats
pour l'apprentissage qui est dans
l'entreprise mans c'est un échec total
j'ai fait observer que dans n'importe
quel pays anglo saxons comme c est à ce
point l'engagement personnel du
président nommé
façon c'est une telle pantomime ce
gouvernement c'est tellement dramatique
de voir les échecs successifs que ce
soit monsieur valls en matière de
sécurité que ce soit monsieur le sapin
matière de chômage que ce soit monsieur
moscovici le ministre du budget en
matière de réduction du déficit
budgétaire mais pouvoir en décompte le
fiasco en vingt mois le socialiste qui
était censé sauver la france de la
politique paraît-il terrible qui était
menée par la majorité ump quand on voit
aujourd'hui ce qu'il en était devenu
c'est une banda terrible à laquelle on
aime à 20h bertinat tient aujourd'hui
le véritable sujet c'est qu'elle va y
avoir des élections municipales qui sont
en train de se transformer en un
véritable vote sanction et moi je le dis
une nouvelle fois votre antenne
j'appelle les français à tirer les
conséquences de ce qu'il voit et
d'exprimer leur colère à travers ce que
j'appelle un vote utile c'est à dire un
vote dès le premier tour pour les
candidats de l'ump c'est la seule
manière d'ailleurs deux marqué un
désaveu très nettes contre françois
hollande s'il veut espérer également à
votre sanction par exemple d'une partie
de la gauche qui a déçu par l'abandon de
certaines réformes de société je me mets
à la place d'un électeur de gauche il
doit être profondément désabusé car
voilà un président de la république qui
leur a promis le rêve vous le
réenchanter le rêve et on voit
aujourd'hui une situation économique et
sociale terrible l'explosion du du
chômage lié à l'explosion des impôts qui
conduit aujourd'hui hélas à un
développement terrible de la précarité
dans notre pays c'est un bailleur michel
grossiord je voudrais le dire sur votre
antenne c'est un non-dit terrible que de
voir aujourd'hui dans notre pays des
millions de français qui se trouvent
aujourd'hui du fait des hausses massives
d'impôts dans des situations véritable
de précarité je pense aux classes
moyennes commerçants artisans patrons de
pme salariés salariés modestes mais bien
sûr vous n'imaginez pas le nombre de mes
administrés à ma permanence que je tiens
en tant que maire amo qui viennent me
dire on n'y arrive plus alors on va
revenir sur la famille mais à propos d
un pays justement il y a des idées dans
l'air notamment qui alimente la
réflexion de certains députés
socialistes pour une moindre
déductibilité de la cg que pensez vous
de cette proposition un nouveau hold up
sur le pouvoir d'achat des français
pouvoir en décompte la csg est un impôt
s'est payée par tous les français et
voilà que la nouvelle idée folle du
rapporteur général du budget qui n'en
est pas à son coup d'essai qui fait
preuve d'ailleurs d'une une approche
idéologique terrible il dit agir à
réfléchir au nom de la progressivité de
l'impôt était toujours des bonnes des
bons arguments c'est comme ça qu'il
expliquait que la taxe à 75% pour les
plus fortunés qui fait hurler le monde
entier qui d'ailleurs n'investit plus en
france la taxe à 75% c'était une
punition une sanction avait il dit des
plus riches parce que c'est une faute
d'être riche en france depuis que les
socialistes sont au pouvoir alors là la
nouvelle folie c'est de dire aux
français vous avez payé de l'impôt sur
le cng et bien maintenant on va vous
faire payer de l'impôt sur le revenu sur
l'impôt que vous avez payé c'est
extrêmement grave 7 on arrive à un
niveau de spoliation du pouvoir d'achat
des français qui est absolument inouïe
inouïe et en le plus incroyable c'est
que tout cela se fait après que le
président de la république ait fait une
conférence de presse il ya maintenant
trois semaines pour de dire j'arrête
tout cela désormais ya plus de hausses
d'impôts il y aura plus de doses du tout
prélèvement tous les cas dudule 1 de
taux d'imposition général où elle a
écouté vous fait un bel effort ski
français l'indéfendable mais moi j'ai
compris que les trop d'impôts certains
j'ai compris ça lui ferait payer plus
d'impôts mais globalement la note ah bah
écoutez ce nantais par l'état c'est pas
de chance parce que ça tombe toujours
sur les classes moyennes c'est à dire
ceux qui n'ont jamais droit à rien et
qui paye pour tout le monde savait je
crois qu'il faut quand même bien voir
qu'on est arrivé là un niveau de 10
paires fiscalité qui étrangle le pays
moi je le vois je sais que je parcours
la france dans tous les sens j'étais
hier en or habite une à lens j'ai parlé
avec beaucoup de jeu de françaises et de
français je croisais dans le tarn
quasiment fait une réunion dans le train
tellement les gens venaient me dire on
ne peut plus on est étranglé par les
impôts des socialistes concernant al
horford sur l'attention alors messieurs
confirmé vouloir fiscalisés la csg
donnera lieu de la part de l'ump à une
dénonciation massives et encore une fois
je dis aux français les élections
municipales première fois qu'ils vont
pouvoir voter depuis les présidentielles
de 2012 ça doit être l'occasion d'un
homme massif et donc
concernant la réforme sur la famille
donc finalement cette réforme elle
reviendra avant la fin du quinquennat
après les municipales entendent claude
berri ça y est je crois que claude
bartolone a tout de suite le fait tomber
le masque en réalité il ya une fracture
profonde au sein de cette majorité
françois hollande est paniqué il a
laissé libre cours à toutes les folies
lui même d'ailleurs il y avait participé
je rappelle que sur la pma parce que
personne ne le dit il est bien tentant
de retrouver les déclarations des uns et
des autres et c'est en tant dans le
magazine têtu effet antoine
ces propositions présidentielles faut
qu'il faut qu'on m'explique là qu'est ce
que c'est alors donc que ce soit c'est
dans les professions présidentielle met
donc ça veut dire que quand on fait une
interview à têtu c'est juste pour aller
chercher des électeurs donc il dit le 29
avril 2012 on est donc quelques jours
avant le deuxième tour de la
présidentielle françois hollande à la
question êtes vous favorable à
l'ouverture de la pma aux couples de
lesbiennes réponse de françois hollande
oui il dit mais oui je les dis ce qui
prouve qu'ils aient donc une répétition
ce qu'il allait oui
c'est un joli mot pour dire simplement
qu'en réalité les socialistes sont en
train de se heurter à la relève c'est
sociales y sont en train de se heurter à
la colère des français qu'est ce qui est
en train de se passer aujourd'hui le
pays réel celui qui vis de l'extérieur
du périphérique parisien est aujourd'hui
en train de dire à françois hollande il
n'ya qu'une seule chose dont vous
devriez vous occuper c'est la baisse du
chômage
la compétitivité et la sécurité des
français or qu'est ce que nous voyons
nous voyons un gouvernement qui tous les
jours sans compter les députés de la
majorité tous les jours viennent
s'immiscer dans la vie privée des
français je voudrais vous dire michel
conscient la chose suivante
la grande leçon qu'on doit tirer de tout
ce qui est en train de se passer la
grande leçon c'est qu'en réalité les
français ne supportent pas que l'on
vienne en permanence depuis le
gouvernement s'immiscer dans leur vie
privée je souhaite moi j'aspire à une
société plus de région de sofia une
société du libre choix laissons les
françaises et les français choisir dans
le cadre des lois existantes leur mode
de vie plutôt que de venir s'occuper de
leur vie conjugale de venir s'occuper et
quand même on pourrait évoquer de l'est
avec la théorie du genre de l'éducation
des enfants pourquoi croyez vous que
tant de français soient inquiets
aujourd'hui le gouvernement multiplie
dénégations sur la théorie du genre sauf
que les documents sont là je les ai
évoqué produits mais c'est de l'égalité
synchronisation des élèves à l'égaler
lorsque vous voyez une convention
interministériel signée par cinq
ministres
cinq ministres en 2013 dans lequel il
est écrit les savoirs scientifiques
issus des recherches sur le genre
nourrir les politiques publiques c'est
écrit en toutes lettres et ses co signé
par monsieur sapin monsieur peillon
madame vallaud belkacem madame fioraso
la défense pouvoir nager de parler non
seulement nos cinq m'écouter non
seulement magie très du tout mais c'est
la réalité mettez vous à la place des
parents je pas si vous êtes père de
famille mais moi je peux vous dire que
je ne cesse de voir autour de moi et et
en tant que père de famille je suis tout
aussi sensibilisés à la question un
certain nombre de nos compatriotes
qu'ils disent mais qu'est ce que le
gouvernement vient s'occuper de faire
des cours sur la théorie du genre alors
que on a un recul de la faim une
aggravation l'illettrisme à l'entrée en
6ème que l'apprentissage est piétinée et
que nous avons les résultats que sur la
famille jean françois copé les députés
sont révoltés ils veulent revenir
effectivement avec leurs propositions
des pulls ou de gauche et député
socialiste mais vous dites ils veulent
s'immiscer dans la vie intime mais il
s'agit de pacifier le divorce il savait
ce qui l'attendait il s'agit par exemple
car il s'agit pas de divorce c'est à
dire parce que vous vous pensez qu en
substituant un jeu le juge actuel des
affaires familiales de leur substituer à
greffier ça va pacifier le divorce c'est
la volonté affichée mais donc la vendée
chaque pour arrêter l'un des combats de
nadine massie part ils sont reçus en
prenons chaque point celui qui consiste
à substituer à greffier au juge aux
affaires familiales pour venir
par un simple coup de tampon homologuer
une convention de divorce c'est
simplement la pire manière de procéder
je suis désolé de dire que la procédure
de divorce et c'est l'avocat qui parle
la procédure de divorce c'est un acte
majeur alors pendant l'autre est rempli
mais non parce que celui là vous avez
raison de le prendre et il fait partie
de ces gens nés de ses lubies de la
chancellerie pour nous dire on va on va
banaliser par exemple un statut du beau
parent jeu c'était un combat par exemple
de la ministre nadine morano a donné un
statut aller à ces personnes qui
s'occupent des enfants mais pendant les
familles recomposées je n'ai pas de
problème avec l'idée d'évoquer un statut
protecteur pour les beaux parents mais
le problème c'est que dans la loi en
question on se moque des français et en
l'occurrence on se moque des députés de
l'opposition on nous dit avec la bouche
en coeur il y aura rien sur la pma et la
gpa sauf que là dans la même semaine
madame fioraso encore ministre nous a
expliqué qu' il pourrait y avoir des
amendements alors après on nous dit oui
mais monsieur valls nous a dit que
monsieur vice ministre de l'intérieur
vous voyez le rapport de dire nommé tout
ce qui concerne la pma ne sera pas
acceptée ah bon mais monsieur leroux
deux heures après a dit assis et si ça
n'est pas sous la forme d'amendements ce
sera une proposition de loi et monsieur
bartolone vient de couper court aux
déclarations de monsieur ayrault à la
demande de monsieur l'homme puisque
monsieur ayrault nous dit c'est reporté
signer dié et monsieur bartoli no 9
s'est remis au lendemain des municipales
monsieur gossio il ya un plan caché et
je crois qu'il est grand temps que celle
qu'elle aurait fait ce plan caché est le
suivant le gouvernement a décidé pour
essayer de limiter les dégâts aux
élections municipales de reporter tous
les textes qui viendraient fâcher les
français pour leur imposer après je
prends dans l'ordre la réforme pénale de
madame taubira un texte
extraordinairement laxiste pour les
délinquants le droit de vote pour les
étrangers dont monsieur hollande parle
de manière récurrente ce qui lui permet
d'ailleurs de jouer avec le front
national la fif la loi sur la famille
qui vient exactement dans la foulée dont
monsieur martin lundi dès le lendemain
des municipales on le remet sur la table
voilà ce qu'il en est alors si vous
ajoutez à tout cela le plan fiscal qui
est en train de se mettre en place
beaucoup plus vite que le soi disant
pacte de responsabilité qui s'étiole
tous les jours le plan fiscal dans
lequel nous allons retrouver la
fiscalisation de la csg qui vient
s'ajouter à toute la mise en cause de la
politique fiscale sur le plan familial
premier rabot du quotient familial à
l'été 2012 deuxième rabot du quotient
familial pour la loi de finances 2014
fiscalisation des majorations de pension
pour les retraités parents de trois
enfants et plus pour financer les
retraites réduction de fête du congé
parental pour la plupart des parents
décidés dans la loi égalité largement
pour douala notamment le père oui vous
savez quand vous avez quand même vu que
quand vous faites le total si jamais les
pères ne le propre à il ya
malheureusement des pertes qui ne
peuvent pas le prendre c'est perdre
ses glorieux vous allez rencontrer
angela merkel oui enfin le 11 février
absolument c'est pas pour prendre une
leçon d'union nationale parce que là bas
ils arrivent à s'entendre sur les grands
enjeux du moment un conservateurs
sociaux démocrates oui mais vous avez vu
que là bas celui qui a initié la
modernisation du marché du travail c'est
un socialiste c'était un des c'était
monsieur hearts qui avait été sollicité
par monsieur schröder premier ministre
social démocrate
nous en sommes très loin aux gens non et
vous discernement qui dit aujourd'hui
même il est temps de s'unir pour
redresser le pays et met en avant le le
graet le pack de responsabilité qui a
l'aval quand même d'une partie de vos
amis à l'unpef a de moins en moins parce
que comprendre ce que des mois j'avais
alerté un j'avais dix minutes et moi de
bien sûr qui peut être contre la seule
chose c'est qu'on va attendre de voir
parce qu'on est habitué avec monsieur
hollande à ce que les promesses ne
soient jamais suivies d'effet c'est pas
hélas la première fois donc qu'est ce
qui se passe aujourd'hui il se passe que
monsieur hollande s'est moqué des
français en leur disant il ya trois
semaines j'ai compris je vais changer de
politique ne change rien du tout les 50
milliards de baisses de dépenses
publiques n'arriveront jamais on l'a
compris depuis déjà trois semaines pas
une seule annonce la seule annonce une
hausse de dépenses ils veulent faire
cinquante mille contrats aidés
supplémentaires la vérité monsieur gros
sûr c'est que ils ne baisseront pas les
dépenses ils vont continuer d'augmenter
les impôts ils ne moderniseront pas le
marché du travail par contre ils sont
capables de mobiliser les français sur
des sujets qui objectivement ne sont
vraiment pas d'urgence qui qui qui
touche à la société française encaisser
tout cela est absolument dramatique je
me mets à la place de nos compatriotes
qui se disent mais comment at on pu se
retrouver dans cette situation d'avoir
un gouvernement socialiste qui a tous
les pouvoirs et qui à ce point les
utilisent pour déstructurer une société
qui au contraire besoin d'apaisement
allez on va parler maintenant des
propositions de l'ump où il ya un autre
sujet qui divise vous n'êtes pas tous
d'accord quand même sur le virage pro
entreprise de françois hollande c'est le
retour maintenant évident de nicolas
sarkozy on en parle dans un instant avec
deborah claude de la sp mais d'abord le
point donc sur ce retour annoncé par
l'intéressé lui même de plus en plus
clairement jérôme bonnard
là où la mer est pas si il revient
l'ancien président n'est pas avare de
métaphores devant les journalistes
c'était jeudi dernier en charente
maritime au fil de ses déplacements
nicolas sarkozy fait visiblement tout
pour se faire désirer une mise en scène
parfaite ça marche très bien avec les
médias mais ça marche derrière les
médias ça marche avec le public à qui on
raconte l'histoire du retour gagnant
d'un homme qui avait perdu et qui
remonte sur le ring et qui gagne en fait
quand on y réfléchit c'est le scénario
de requis 2 même si la ressemblance
n'est pas évident au premier abord en
fait tout est dans la subtilité car en
envoyant ses cartes postales nicolas
sarkozy s'adresse aussi et surtout à ses
concurrents les ténors de l'ump et là
encore vive les comparaisons les fans de
harry potter apprécieront peut-être
m'est arrivé aussi de le comparer à
voldemort c'est à dire que c'est celui
dont on ne prononce jamais le nom mais
auquel tout le monde pense à l'ump et
dont le retour est forcément inéluctable
mais peut-on parler d'un retour gagnant
nicolas sarkozy l'homme providentiel pas
question de laisser émerger une relève à
droite pas question de primaires en 2016
60% des sympathisants souhaitent son
retour et il peut compter sur les
indétrônables lieutenant et autres
fidèles supporteurs mais les fameuses
cartes postales n'atteignent visiblement
pas tous les destinataires la méthode
sarkozy a peut être aussi ses limites
gare aux phénomènes d'illusions c'est à
dire de vouloir faire une tactique qui
soit profondément contraire à ce qui
l'est c'est terre que nicolas sarkozy ce
n'est pas quelqu'un qui attend d'être
réclamé dans son caractère nicolas
sarkozy c'est bonaparte ce n'est pas
pierre mendès france décidément les
comparaisons vont bon train côté ump
certains en rajoute même une couche tout
en laissant place à une certaine
ambiguïté le général de gaulle notamment
des prix mais alors si les revenus voilà
et il était le bienvenu quand jean
françois copé s'est présenté il a dit si
nicolas revient je serai à ses côtés
eh bien c'est dit que la reviens moi
aussi je serai à ses côtés à partir ce
moment là on fait un syllogisme et nous
nous retrouvons au côté de jean françois
copé aujourd'hui comme demain
voilà entre syllogisme donc le cas
charon et puis comparaison de nicolas
sarkozy avec la mère qui reviens
toujours bon soir des bombes à ce moment
question à jean françois copé sur l'ump
donc ça l'ump sur sur rocchi 2 puisque
là c'est est ce qu'on me disait dans le
sujet alors est ce que nicolas sarkozy
ait une espérance pour la france comme
nous l'a dit brice hortefeux la semaine
dernière elle a dit sur les ondes de rtl
est-ce qu'il va y avoir un retour de
l'ancien chef d'aller faire ça je peux
pas vous répondre je n'en sais
strictement rien moi toute façon vous
savez quel est votre ma position je les
dis nombreuses reprises simplement je
veux juste vous livrer une réflexion
supplémentaire je pense que aujourd'hui
ce qui compte ce n'est pas ce n'est pas
ça pour les français les français vivent
au quotidien une situation très durs
ceux qui ont voté pour françois hollande
sont aujourd'hui les fondre est désabusé
déçu ceux qui ont voté pour nicolas
sarkozy
se disent vraiment quel gâchis depuis 20
mois et aujourd'hui nous sommes dans une
étape nouvelle je pense que la france de
2014 n'est plus celle de 2012 mais
qu'elle n'est pas encore celle de 2017
ce qui compte aujourd'hui nation
d'espérance est ce que nicolas sarkozy
incarne oui ou non une aspirine espérant
se lance je n'ai pas de doute un instant
bien sûr qu'il incarne une espérance
mais encore une fois aujourd'hui ce qui
compte c'est qu'elle projet qu'est ce
que nous proposons aux français et moi
même a bien sûr encore 2010 elle se
serait passé des choses je me sens et
vous me sens pas ses 1000 mais en même
temps on essaie quand même d'organiser
des primaires de bordés ça c'est autre
chose les primaires c'est autre chose
mais encore une fois
comprenez moi ma mission n'est pas tout
à fait la même que celle des autres
notamment de mes aînés moi je suis dans
l'action il en est qui peuvent se
permettre
ce coup sa fille bien sur wii ou
d'autres
non mais attendez il tonné
ma mission n'est pas la même il en est
parmi eux qui peuvent se permettre de ne
pas parler d'être silencieux de ne pas
être dans le combat quotidien en
revanche pour moi c'est interdit moi je
suis comme dans le combat quotidien oui
j'aime pas beaucoup cette expression est
ce que je la trouve un peu péjoratif ce
que je vais les élections ce que je fais
oui plusieurs semaines vous répéter
encore tout à l'heure les municipales il
faut voter ump aux municipales ça très
bien non même
situation non je répète simplement oui
voilà c'est une citation merci donc
qu'effectivement vous vous êtes là pour
le mois de mars prochain et les
européens sur les européennes et ensuite
j'ai encore les sénatoriales les
cantonales et régionales ce que je veux
juste vous dire c'est que ma mission
elle est que ma famille politique renoue
avec la victoire nous n'avons pas gagné
d'élections locales depuis 2001 rythme
depuis 2001 une éternité et donc quelque
part ce qui compte aujourd'hui c'est que
les français sachent qu'ils ingèrent de
l'opposition qui est tous les jours
au combat au sens noble du terme et ont
départagé de l'ombre permanente de
nicolas sarkozy traduit un manque de
leadership à droite sans vous
n'empêcherez jamais
2 les envieux de grâce est mais tel
n'est pas le sujet aujourd'hui ce qui
compte pour moi c'est que nous ayons une
ligne politique alors c'est moi que nous
ayons des candidats des investis dans
les milieux des débats quand même entre
vous mais sur la ligne sur la ligne au
bout choco d'accord j'ai des débuts sont
passionnants et la ligne politique elle
a été acté il ya un grand n'ya rien fait
nous vend quand même on a fait un
conseil national c'est à dire jeux wii
fin janvier le dressage en
face à tant d 4 93% de vote favorable de
tous les cas c'est un moment très
important au contraire ça a été adoptée
à l'unanimité à la fois par le mes amis
de l'équipe dirigeante et ensuite par
93% des personnes et des commandes comme
françois baroin alain juppé qui ont
prouvé que votre votre avis vous la
tribu est trop libérez vous l'avez
évoqué tout à l'heure dans la première
partie de cette émission jean françois
copé sur les baisses d'impôts ce que
vous annoncez sur les économies
budgétaires 130 milliards d'euros sur
ces été adopté là où siècle vous avez
les aux questions des militants
réveiller lequel il ya enfin la
modernisation
du marché du travail a subi concrètement
par exemple ça veut dire quoi vous
pourriez par exemple imaginer une
modulation du smic voire la suppression
du smic oh non c'est pas ça que j'ai
pensé non on a pensé à bien d'autres
choses on a pensé par exemple à l'idée
de deux d'en finir avec les 35 heures
est de dire désormais c'est la
négociation par entreprise ou par
branches qui va faire le temps de
travail l'organisation dans l'entreprise
plutôt que ces espèces d' immense barnum
21 interprofessionnelle où on mélange le
secteur du btp le secteur du nucléaire
le numérique l'hôtellerie et serra do
petit pic mans ont signé avec les 35
heures dans le secteur privé mais aussi
dans l'administration
imaginez demain des fonctionnaires moins
nombreux mais mieux considérer mieux
payés
repenser caisse quand on dit mais c'est
230 milliards c'est 10% des dépenses
publiques aujourd'hui un ménage une
entreprise dans la difficulté est bien
le people lui arrivait de faire 10%
d'économies pas vous partie de ces
gérants préfèrent on peut faire 130
milliards d'économies budgétaires ou
l'état l'elysée
marie thérèse baisser les impôts en
m'amenant des français c'est ce que va
vous avez forcément lu ce qu'on a écrit
vous êtes des gens attentifs qu'est ce
qu'on a dit on a dit qu'on fait 130
milliards de baisses de dépenses
publiques et que dans ses 130 milliards
ont fait 65 milliards de baisses
d'impôts et 65 milliards de baisse de la
dette bon il s'agit en vérité de faire
ce que tous les autres pays qui s'en
sortent en europe ont fait avant nous
l'allemagne l'espagne la grande bretagne
c'est ce travail là alors après vous
dites ou non n'est pas d'accord écoutez
d'abord mettait pas alain juppé dans le
lot des gens pas d'accord ils étaient
présents il a voté et il m'a téléphoné
pour me dire qu'il était tout à fait en
phase bon donc là dessus nous arrêtons
de le faire parler à sa place pour le
reste vous n'empêcherez par plusieurs
familles pour les européennes il va
falloir concilier des positions ça c'est
encore autre chose à dire dans cinq ans
voire selva vous parlez aussi si
longtemps non mais deborah je ne suis
pas de problème on va parler aussi des
européennes juste pour finir sur le
projet économique il peut y avoir ici ou
là vous n'empêcherez pas tel ou tel vous
dire qu'il est content c'est pas grave
qu'une minorité pourquoi est-ce qu'à
gauche il se tape tous dessus c'est
frais et printanier à droite c'était
absolument catastrophique on a plutôt
l'habitude que ça bah non c'est faux
c'est comment la droite mais
l'ajustement on a vraiment eu à une
énigme limité très forte pourquoi
d'ailleurs je vais vous dire c'est très
simple qu'est ce qu'ils veulent les
français qu'est ce qu'ils veulent quand
on parle avec eux qu'ils soient
d'ailleurs d'où il faudra qu'ils vous
disent quoi hein on veut plus de liberté
économique on n'en peut plus des
contrôles l'inspection du travail des
rigidités des impôts et déjà plus de
liberté économique
2 les français nous disent on veut
rétablir l'autorité de l'état ça tombe
bien c'est dans notre projet et trois
votes de l'égalité des chances l'égalité
des droits et des devoirs légalité des
efforts pourquoi l'état fait jamais
défaut alors que nous avons fait ben
voilà le projet de l'ump se sont faites
vous taper dessus les français dans le
train quand vous parlez à vos côtés pour
tout vous dire il peut arriver qu'il le
dise mais il est vrai que c'est une
question vous nous posez beaucoup plus
souvent que d'accord parce que vous vous
êtes énormément là dessus alors qu'en
réalité quand on fait l'inventaire des
choses ça va pas si mal que ça à l'ump
quand je vois ce que nous étions à la
fin 2012 désir dans cette période à la
fois de deuil après des élections
présidentielles nous avions perdu et de
crise interne à la suite de mon élection
bon entre-temps l'année 2013 je l' ai
consacré à rassembler et réconcilier
j'ai déjà refusé fait un choix qui
consistait à dire pour y arriver je ne
répond plus aux injures aux insultes et
aux caricatures dont j'ai été l'objet ça
m'a pesé 1 parce qu on a dit des
horreurs sur moi et pourtant je me suis
dit il faut accepter la dessus de ne
rien dire pour rassembler les gens et
tourner la page et c'est grâce à ça
qu'on a eu un conseil national les gens
étaient un peu obsédé par les primaires
mais est-ce que les primaires finalement
ça oui déjà un il renvoie à leur terme
première question et deuxièmement est ce
que finalement c'est pas une machine à
réactiver la compétition interne en
permanence des questions voilà de quoi
bon est ce que certains pour sa maison
votre écoute et moi quand c'est la
gauche qui fait déprimer on dit que
c'est démocratique quand c'est la droite
qui fait des poneys on dit c'est la
machine à s'entretuer faudrait savoir
oui mais parce que c'est bonaparte et un
kit 2
et d'ailleurs
ça veut dire quoi lancer il ya soixante
hommes et 102 de gens qui veulent un
candidat il y aura pas de primaires
c'est la question c'est la question
écoutez
je vais vous dire ce soir en tant que
président de l'ump vous avez mis sur les
rails effectivement les primaires est-ce
qu'il ira jusqu'à son terme ce qui est
des statuts il erra jusqu'à sa galerie
statut ses statuts ont été adoptés à une
écrasante majorité il pourrait défaire
une écrasante majorité des gamins d'à
côté c'est pas drôle r non mais c'est
une question que vous posez mais
pourquoi ils le seraient effacées pas
comme ça que ça marche des des statuts
qui ont été adopté qui prévoit beaucoup
de choses donc une primaire donc moi je
suis aujourd'hui garonne ce statut comme
le sont d'ailleurs tous les toutes les
personnes physiques il est qui les ont
élaboré et soumis aux va pas passer par
cette primaire serait un risque pour le
mp2 division justement au premier tour
de la présidentielle avec le reste
écoutez si vous avez cinq candidats de
l'ump qu'on n'a pas départagé avant
qu'ils se retrouvent candidat à la
présidentielle au premier tour c'est un
problème nicolas sarkozy toile c'est
encore une soirée les centristes à votre
primeur une petite question comme ça à
long terme oat et j'en sais rien je
faillis long j'imagine leur propre
désignation de candidats j'ai pas
réfléchi à s'affaisser nous on a des
centristes à l'ump vous évoquiez jean
pierre raffarin marc philippe daubresse
il ya que tout d'un courant humaniste et
centriste qui est très important à l'ump
mais tu vas juste vous dire la chose
suivante je vous en ai déjà dit beaucoup
sur les primaires je peux pas vous en
dire plus pour une raison simple c'est
que moi aujourd'hui mon agenda numéro un
c'est l'année qui vient c'est des
municipales c'est les européennes c'est
les sénatoriales c'est pour ça que je
vous disais tout à l'heure il en est qui
peuvent se taire parler une fois tous
les 36 du mois avoir une parole rare
donc très oxygénée c'est pas mon cas moi
je suis amené
de personnes six t2 est nominé est en
deuil a pas besoin de mettre des noms il
ya des gens qui n'étant pas en
responsabilité immédiate n'ont pas
besoin de parler tous les jours
dans la place qui est la mienne comme
mon ami christian jacob à la présidence
du groupe à l'assemblée nationale nous
sommes au combat tous les jours parce
que parce que c'est notre rôle sa
mission avait enduré au plus fort de la
bataille pour la présidence avec
françois fillon s'en souvient
effectivement mais quand vous entendez
aujourd'hui henri guaino qui lui a été
traité de joueur de grosse caisse c'est
à dire que vous êtes un joueur de pipeau
vous encaissez encore la non monsieur
rien c'est pas grave alors une fois
mettons pas tout s'il faut faire la
liste de tous à face à aucun sens c'est
pas grave bon ok on connaît son
tempérament il s'était il s'était mis
voilà il s'emporte souvent ici encore
jean luc romero c'est
bon mais chacun sont tempérées mer et
sam à vous m'avez répondu sur l'agly fin
janvier jérôme est ce que ça peut coûter
peu importe tout ça franchement ce n'est
pas du niveau si vous le permettez de
notre entretien qui je crois en gage
d'abord la préoccupation des français
qu'est ce que nous proposons face à la
politique de l'agglomération sur
l'europe justement on les veut pas que
sur le kosovo position il ya un sondage
que nous ramène à henri guaino dayori
son âge qui est sorti il ya deux ou
trois semaines effectivement on tout on
était un peu dans un mouchoir de poche
enfin pas du tout aussi on parle du même
jeu sur les intentions de vote oui c'est
ça pas du tout les corps
d'état c'est là où je pense qu'il est
vraiment important que puisque vous dans
votre métier vous êtes tellement attaché
à lire les sondages vous voulez lié à
une chose en commun
et moi c'était une chose qui m'a
beaucoup frappé gg je fréquente beaucoup
vos confrères de la presse
internationale ils sont eux-mêmes
impressionnée elle voir combien vos
jugements sont d'abord orientée par le
sondage dire que vous pouvez être un
ministre nulle si vos sondages sont très
bons personne n'en dira du mal
al'inverse si jamais vos sondages sont
mauvais ou pouvez même faire des choses
familières que ça marchera pas nageurs
peut-être que c'est
juste une chose moi ils ont le
correctement quête côté ce dernier
sondage premièrement le front national
perd trois points personne n'a écrit
deuxièmement nous sommes dans la marge
d'erreur autre front national et l'ump
pour
écouter je crois que c'est 23 pour l'un
à 22 pour l'autre bon et deuxième
élément vous dites un mouchoir de poche
que vous avez vu ce mouchoir vous le ps
s'effondre il est derrière le vrai fait
nouveau c'est que le ps s'effondre comme
prévu d'ailleurs oui bon donc je
recommande quand même qu'on ne
surévaluent pas en permanence sous
prétexte qu'il faut faire vendre le
front national dont chacun peut
constater aujourd'hui évalué pour vous
emmener dans les commentaires déjà une
chose que les sondages ne montrent pas
ses taux d'abstention ne sera forcément
très fort à gauche comment voulez vous
qu'un électeur de gauche est envie
d'aller voter aujourd'hui pour un
candidat socialiste qui va lui dire je
soutiens françois hollande tellement il
est formidable alors on l'a dit tout à
l'heure dernière question comme sur le
positionnement européen on a envie de
savoir parce que vous détenez y
politique
redresser sur la question européenne est
question n'est ce pas deborah vous avez
des chez vous des souverainistes des
gens qui sont un petit peu plus heureux
70e
oui il y en a mais le vrai sujet n'est
pas celui là le vrai sujet est le
suivant
l'ump est profondément européenne je
suis profondément européen mais mon
identité est française et en même temps
à l'intérieur de l'europe où nous
commémorons le centenaire de 14-18 ont
peut-être quelques-uns à rappeler à nos
concitoyens que l'europe dans laquelle
nous vivons aujourd'hui une europe de
paix en même temps j'aime passionnément
l'europe et donc je me sens très libre
pour dire que j'en veux une autre que je
veux profondément la changer que je veux
une europe efficace une europe qui
protège les citoyens une europe qui
protège nos marchés quand les marchés
américains se protègent ou les marchés
chinois se protège je veux une
harmonisation fiscale et sociale bref je
veux qu réécrivent schengen bref il ya
toute une série de sujets nous aurons
l'occasion d'en reparler sur lequel je
veux changer l'europe mais ma grande
différence et celle de mes amis avec le
front national c'est que le front
national veut sortir de l'europe veut
organiser le suicide du pays en sortant
en revenant au franc français qui
ruinerait immédiatement d millions de
salariés et de retraités quant au parti
socialiste excusez moi ils portent la
responsabilité numéro 1 de
l'affaiblissement de la france en europe
à travers sur le comportement du
président république face à madame
merkel donc permettez moi de vous dire
que sur ces sujets nous avons
effectivement lee qui est très très
offensive oui nous aimons l'europe mais
on en veut une autre merci d'abord aller
troisième partie de l'émission tout de
suite avec un père internautes qui nous
rejoint vous avez dit que vous avez
souffert de votre image lors de cette
guerre au sommet pour l'ump
l'image de françois fillon a également
parlé un peu depuis mounir souci
pour la saison 2 de sa présidence à
l'ump jean françois copé veut changer de
rôle fini le costume de méchants de
service après être passé pour la brute à
l'issue de son duel avec françois fillon
ils cherchent à se mettre dans les
habits du bon ses premières
interventions médiatiques du mois de
janvier étaient des interventions
beaucoup plus douce beaucoup plus en
rondeur moins cassant - carey moins
directe et essayer surtout d'éviter les
critiques avec des gays des camarades de
parti un pari raté ce week end il a
échangé des noms d'oiseaux avec henri
guaino des conflits qui brouille son
image
résultat à droite même manuel valls est
plus populaire que lui des sondages pas
qui n'incite pas à changer de ligne lui
laissait pas de deux de jouer un autre
une autre musique qui est plutôt celle
justement de ces de ses rivaux qui
essaie de se positionner pack de
responsabilité c'est acceptable dit jean
pierre raffarin on peut peut-être faire
un bout de chemin 10 quelques cadres a
donc lui par contre il n'est pas du tout
dans cette voie là et quand ils
attaquent la gauche ils attaquent
frontalement son opération reconquête
peine à convaincre installé dans une
opposition mécanique au gouvernement le
chef de l'ump a du mal à se défaire de
son personnage de francs tireurs mais at
il vraiment le choix il fait le job
être président en grande partie ça n'est
pas facile tous les jours il ya des
difficultés tous les jours il faut
arbitrer et tous les jours il faut
porter le message qui est le nôtre
prochain test de popularité grandeur
nature dans les urnes lors des
municipales
un événement qui permettra de savoir si
l'ump son président peuvent revenir en
haut de la fiche
voilà perrine tarneaud est avec nous
bonsoir perrine vos questions à jean
françois copé dans saint michel bonsoir
jean françois copé vous aviez dit que
2013 c'était l'année de l'apaisement à
ce que 2014 sera l'année de la
reconquête pour lui je le crois je le
crois vraiment je vous disais tout à
l'heure que la france de 2014 n'est plus
celle de 2012 il ya l'ump 2014 n'est
plus non plus celle de 2012 et les
images que vous montriez de ce conseil
national en ont été je crois là la
démonstration la plus belle qui soit une
famille politique qui s'est rassemblée
sur les idées je dis pas qu'il peut pas
y avoir ici ou là des querelles de
personnes
mais oui mais mais elle considère un peu
longues années merci de bien vouloir au
moins vous le reconnaître ce n'est pas
dramatique vous avez déjà d iliad et il
ya des égos il ya des personnalités il
ya des histoires différentes je cherche
une chose et je voudrais vraiment vous
veillez cela en tête et que nos
auditeurs le comprenne bien je ne ferai
pas de synthèse à l'eau tiède entre les
uns et les autres c'était la technique
de françois hollande quand il était le
chef du ps moi je n'aime pas ça une
ligne politique ça doit être une ligne
audible courageuse moi je me bats pour
des idées depuis des années j'ai une
grande constance dans ses convictions
pour la france liberté économique
autorités de l'état égalité des chances
et des droits et des devoirs et ses
idées que j'ai exposé que j'ai écrites
dans le manifeste pour une droite
décomplexée c'est pour moi très
attention vous êtes prêt quand même à
garder quelques inimitiés au sein de
l'ump chien mais personne n'a envie
d'inimitié mais je crois qu'il ya deux
choses vous avez des inimitiés
personnelles qui peuvent souvent relevé
faut bien dire de jalousie voilà il n'y
a pas là rien à faire après vous pouvez
avoir non pas des inimitiés mais des
divergences mais c'est très sain depuis
quand on imagine qu'un grand parti
politique trois cent vingt mille
militants sept premiers partis militants
de france
exige qu'on aligne tout le monde nous
avons rassemblé les famille gaulliste
dont je suis issue centristes libéraux
radicaux enfin tous et tous ces gens
d'une histoire ce qui compte c'est ce
qui nous rassemble donc vous fait le job
c'est ce que disait jean claude gaudin
dans le reportage convient de voir elle
vous l'avais dit à plusieurs reprises
dans l'émission vous lui aussi les mains
il le fait je veux dire que le combat
qu'ils mènent à marseille et héroïque
moi je pouvais bien souvent sur
marseille justement avec la candidature
cette semaine deux pôles du ouf est ce
que c'est un bon point pour jean claude
gaudin dans le sens où ça va plutôt dans
le sens de la division de la gauche à
marseille crois surtout que face à une
majorité sortante celle de jean claude
gaudin et tous ceux qui l'entourent qui
est un bilan remarquable dans de très
nombreux domaines à marseille vous avez
une gauche qui est profondément divisée
qui essaient de se retrouver
ponctuellement pressés de se partager
les places mais qui est profondément
divisé
l'école guérini d'un côté mennucci de
l'autre puis voilà pape diouf qui vient
se mettre au milieu tout ça montre qui à
part un projet très puissant et je
voudrais puisque vous me posez la
question vous dire que je suis comme je
crois beaucoup de france est scandalisée
de voir la manière dont les ministres
socialistes défilent à marseille quand
je vois les mauvaises polémique qu'ils
ont cherché à nicolas sarkozy en
d'autres temps j'espère qu'on va prendre
on va intégrer dans le compte de
campagne de monsieur mennucci les
déplacements à grands frais de tous ses
ministres puisqu'on parle des
municipales et qu'on parlait les
divisions à droite à paris nkm qui est
de plus en plus distancée dans les
sondages par sa rivale anne hidalgo
qu'est ce qui ne marche pas dans sa
campagne les distances et j'ai encore
des sondages dans le 5e arrondissement
où florence berthou fait un score qui
est très encourageant à deux mois des
élections municipales
j'ajoute que les sondages soyez prudente
parce qu'en réalité ils ne mesurent pas
le taux d'abstention personne ne sait
que si les socialistes vocale est
vraiment voter pour soutenir leurs
remises et vous la réalisation la
nouvelle abstention de gauche l'a
manifestement pour les prochains
scrutins ce n'est pas moi qui le dit
c'est à dire c'est unique
la crainte de tous ceux qui se disent
maintien si les gens vont pas voter à
gauche il se passera quoi alors la
campagne de nathalie mais moi je vais te
le fais une campagne formidable dans des
cours dans un contexte épouvantable
monsieur delanoë madame hidalgo autre
est tellement verrouillé leurs systèmes
arrondissement par arrondissement
donc tous et une taxe est difficile à
droite avec les divisions il dissidence
un message bien sûr tout le monde et
redonne des dissidences mai mais en même
temps
le jour de l'élection les électeurs ils
vont voter utile vous savez quel est le
sujet premier monsieur delanoë il a mis
paris par terre aujourd'hui paris est
complètement étouffé bon du point de vue
du rayonnement économique du rayonnement
culturel cette capitale mondiale n'a
plus de souffle donc je souhaite de tout
coeur que nathalie kosciusko morizet
puisse insuffler avec la génération qui
est la sienne notre dynamique pour paris
bien sûr je souhaite pour les parisiens
sur europe 1 il ya un matin vous avez
dit jean françois copé que les médias
ont embrayé le pas à manuel valls avec
une aisance qui devient franchement anti
démocratique qu'est ce que vous voulez
un exemple et un journaliste ont tous
des vendus non sans ajouter que ce
succès soit vous faites du mal
inutilement n'aurait coûté par les deux
médias anti démocratique non je ne
permettrai pas et j'ai appris grecs non
non non je n'aime pas parler de médias
anti démocratique j'ai dit que c'était
un
positionnement qui pouvaient poser un
vrai quelques jours d'un exemple
observer tout de suite comprendre
monsieur valls fait une interview chez
vos confrères du jdd dimanche dernier
longue interview
trois jours avant il a présenté il était
obligé des résultats catastrophiques en
matière de lutte contre l'immigration
clandestine
et de lutte contre la délinquance des
résultats dignes de ce qu'avait fait
monsieur vaillant 15 ans avant il ne lui
a pas été posé une seule question sur ce
sujet dans cette interview trouvez pas
ça troublant
comme vous le défendez bien c'est je ne
sais pas on va dire on va dire celui de
vos confrères qui n'a pas pensé à
valider et vous me dites ça parce que
vous pensez que nous quand on est
interrogé on est loin en permanence à
toutes les questions je veux juste vous
dire une chose le verra la délinquance
étaient dix jours avant il me semble que
l'idée dé on avait parlé dans son
édition du dimanche précédent bientôt
des excusez-moi l'immigration c'est
toujours avant celle vendredi c'était le
vendredi d'ailleurs on a été un certain
nombre à même se demander si moon manuel
valls ne faisait pas monter cette espèce
de 2 da proches qui a scandalisé tout le
monde de comparaison avec les années 30
qui était une honte pour masquer pour
masquer ses mauvais résultats mais que
celui qui l'interrogent n'est pas la
présence d'esprit surge pas combien six
ou sept questions tant poser au moins
une pour dire ce que vous n'avez pas un
problème avec les résultats de votre
politique ça en dit quand même long sur
le fait que quand un ministre de
l'intérieur à des sondages élevé on
n'ose pas le contester or je prétends
dans cette affaire le sujet majeur c'est
les restes sont les résultats de ce
gouvernement qui dans tous les registres
de l'action publique des résultats
catastrophiques et ça c'est inacceptable
alors quand aux manifestations et la
manière dont manuel valls en a parlé je
le redis sur votre antenne il est
absolument scandaleux qu'il est osé
faire un parallèle avec les années 30
par là il parlait de la du jour de
colère d'accord vous avez compris que
leur dire il ya un intérêt compris
monsieur gossio et qu'il a de manière
extrêmement méthodique créer les
conditions de présentation de la
manifestation d'avant-hier de dimanche
dernier qui était une manifestation pour
le coup pacifique et qui n'avait rien à
voir avec les délires extrémistes que
j'ai moi-même condamné de la semaine
d'avant et que le fait de vouloir les
amalgames et n'a qu'une seule main un
seul objectif repris en boucle par tous
les ministres et par certains médias et
l'asse d'expliquer qu'il ya un complot
qui unirait la droite et l'extrême
droite or je n'accepterai jamais ce
procès d'intention concernant la manif
est jamais toléré la moindre alliance
avec l'extrême droite contrairement à la
gauche qui fait de l'alliance avec
l'extrême gauche l'alpha et l'oméga de
sa conquête concernant la manifestation
de dimanche dernier vous avez rappelé
votre constance il ya un instant jean
françois copé sur les grands sujets
économiques notamment vous vous êtes
engagés pour la laïcité fortement part
régulièrement mais ça ne vous gêne pas
de voir dans la rue quand même des
rassemblements qui unissent une droite
chrétienne très conservatrice et puis
des musulmans rigoriste voir intégristes
bâclé moi je n'ai pas fait
l'inventaire de ceux qui manifestaient
ou pas dimanche en entendu les
témoignages
oui la modification des occasions mais
encore une fois je trouve qu'on fait un
peu trop parlé tel ou tel manifestant
c'est le charme des chaînes
d'information permanente on est un peu
dans dans une hyper actualité je
voudrais juste dire la chose suivante
chacun sait oui enfin faut le faire de
manière scientifique alors pascal mais
il faut compter et personne ne compte on
se contente d'une image et puis ça
permet de prendre un angle et
malheureusement sur le moment on n'a pas
de chance dans ce pays c'est toujours
comme ça mais je veux juste vous dire
une chose mon combat contre le
communautarisme contre l'extrémisme
contre l'intégrisme est un combat
constant et celles et ceux qui veulent
bien suivre les engagements qui ont
toujours été les miens le savent c'est
pour moi la condition d'une laïcité
positive dans le pays c'est à dire
la liberté pour chacun d'exercer son
culte à condition qu'il respecte celui
des autres qu'ils respectent les lois de
la république je veux juste faire
observer une chose je suis frappé de
voir comment des millions de français
quelle que soit leur confession et quels
que soient leur intensité de pratiques
qu'il soit très religieux ou pas très
religieux c'est pas interdit d'être très
religieux ça fait aussi partie de la
liberté mais je suis frappé de voir
comme tant de françaises et de français
sont simplement choqué dans leur
intimité dans les projets
gouvernementaux comme ci est ce que vous
êtes assez d'entendre le gouvernement
frappe est peut-être un peu dépassé peu
par un mouvement que vous ne maîtrisez
pas d'ailleurs vous n'aviez pas appelés
à rejoindre cette manie chez sa mamie je
suis pour tous deux lors mais pourquoi
vous me dites pas vu venir c'est plus de
douceur qu'on n'a pas vu venir j'ai dit
depuis toujours le chanteur usait et
comprenait parfaitement le message des
français qui manifestent ils sont
exaspérés et vous avez vu il y avait pas
de banderoles extrémistes y avait juste
et centaines de milliers de français à
paris à lyon qui en ont juste assez
content de voir un gouvernement
s'immiscer dans leur vie privée dans
leur vie intime et qui le disent alors
après on dit c'est pas appelé mais je
n'ai pas vocation à être dans la rue à
chaque fois que des français conteste
françois hollande moi je suis désolé je
suis par ailleurs omniprésent grâce à
vous dans les médias à l'assemblée jeudi
comme mes amis de l'ump
combien je tout le mal que je peux
penser tous ces projets socialistes mais
enfin après chacun organise sa propre
bien sûr opposition c'est normal vous
demandez toujours la démission de michel
sapin
a très vite et la semaine prochaine il a
déclaré il a dit bruce et le degré zéro
de la demande et ma démission c'est
peut-être un message à lui faire passer
lui transmettre à la semaine prochaine
je pense qu'il ya tellement peu de il ya
tellement peu d'humilité dans tout cela
enfin je sais pas je serai ministre du
travail vous serez engagé
personnellement sur un résultat je suis
désavoué au delà de tout par la
politique que je conduis l'honnêteté
intellectuelle c'est d'en tirer les
conséquences
dieu sait s'ils passent leur temps à
taper sur leurs prédécesseurs il a bon
dos l'héritage ma faim maintenant ça
fait deux ans donc l'héritage ça va pas
pouvoir le faire encore très longtemps
jean françois copé merci merci avoir été
avec nous cette semaine merci père il
donc à la semaine prochaine avec le
ministre du travail on poursuivra bien
sûr ce dialogue à distance
merci à tous et donc à très vite
le club des municipales c'est le rendez
vous dédié aux élections municipales au